my whole life is a very funny story
[Music]
you want me to introduce myself my name
is
david s wisnia
i am 90 years old a holocaust survivor
of close to three years in
auschwitz when i arrived in auschwitz
itself
right after being tattooed
with my number i looked up at the
assessment before
that who was standing in front of me my
eyes were fixed into his belt
buckle cut mitt uns which means
god is with us i said to myself
god is not with you and i'm going to
outlive you
the first couple of weeks in auschwitz
were murder
literally murder because my job was
collecting bodies one night
about two weeks of dragging bodies the
cell block leader says who can sing
of course everybody knew wisnier sang
i got down and performed and that made
me
a privileged prisoner i completely
totally removed my past for me when i
came to hoboken new jersey
and i became a full-fledged cantor
i composed a couple of songs that are in
the museum
in washington while in auschwitz one of
them is in polish about
[Music]
auschwitz
[Music]
december 1944 nazis began
evacuating auschwitz i was on one of the
transports
arriving in dhaka i realized i could not
survive the hou
because in auschwitz i was a privileged
prisoner i was looking for a way to get
out of taha
i decided i was going to
escape as we were emptying the railroad
cars into the ditches
i found the shovel there anyway i made
my way
i walked towards the fire towards the
front not knowing
exactly where i was going i heard
a roar off a huge
column of tanks the whole column stopped
for me
out of the hatch comes out james l
walker
from south carolina i asked him to get
me somebody who speaks polish
he was worse than the one who spoke
english anyway
i became a part of that outfit
never left them until i came to the
united states
because i speak german i talk down
towards the
end of april and the beginning of may
in austria some of the assessed to throw
away their
arms and i made sure that they
understood that we would
treat them as war prisoners
creeks kefangene
and that's exactly what happened
i came home and found my family dead
massacred
and to the best of my knowledge i
eventually found out that my
father resisted
and they found a gun and they killed my
whole family
i really now understand
maybe not for the same reason when the
pope comes to the united states or any
place he kisses the ground
well let me tell you i kissed the ground
of the united states
because i really understand what america
is all about
what i have thank god is a beautiful
family here
a wife now for 69 years and i love to
say
i still have hope that's her name hope
and my grandson thank god happens to be
quite a pianist
he finally after many tries of all kinds
of composers
you know to translate my song from
polish
to english he did it about a couple of
months ago
and now we have it in english and i'm
going to perform it tonight
go ahead
i remember it so clearly
my days in austrian team
got out alive just nearly
still the name stings
still i see that place enduring like the
scars i
can't erase
appel upstand meets an
app that's german hear the sharp ears
call
you wish you were just never born at all
[Music]
through pain and sickness always working
or shrinking with death behind you
always lurking ocean
[Music]
never mind the hope of fling hunger is
the only feeling
ashwinchin like numbers on my arm it
lingers
i curse you with my broken fingers
austrian dream or
shrinches heartbeat hardness stone
[Music]
hatred is the greenest
weed you've grown
[Music]
have a little respect for the next
person don't care who
they are because actually prejudice
hate winds up being
death give up yourself
you'll get it back
[Music]
is